revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y Marta Moya Ya está lista
con nosotros en el estudio Marta buena
mañana de jueves hoy vamos a empezar
nuestra revista de prensa en Irán porque
se cumplen dos meses del inicio de las
protestas esto tras la muerte de la
joven iraní macsa aminí que estuvo bajo
custodia policial en paralelo también
las autoridades iraníes empezar Marta
condenar a muerte a algunos de esos
manifestantes que están en las calles
del país vamos a con un comunicado de
prensa que hizo la organización amnistía
internacional y luego vamos con más
prensa Buenos días Raúl vamos a empezar
con este comunicado de amnistía que
titula escalofriante uso de la pena de
muerte para sofocar de manera brutal el
levantamiento popular cita a la
directora adjunta de amnistía en Oriente
medio a Diana el tahui que textualmente
dice dos meses después del levantamiento
popular y tres años después de las
protestas de noviembre de 2019 la crisis
de impunidad que prevalece en Irán está
permitiendo a las autoridades iraníes no
solo continuar perpetrando asesinatos en
masa sino también intensificar el uso de
la pena de muerte como herramienta las
autoridades han penado dice amistad
internacional al menos a 21 personas a
la pena capital desde que iniciaron las
protestas en el mes de septiembre con
falsos juicios diseñados para intimidar
a quienes participan en estas protestas
desde el 13 de noviembre cita amnistía
tribunales revolucionarios enteran han
condenado al menos a cinco personas por
delitos de enemistad contra Dios y
corrupción en la tierra que es el
Washington
post hace un artículo que titula Irán
ataca periodistas locales en el
extranjero mientras se enfrenta a la
revuelta de su país sostiene este
artículo del Washington post que tanto
disidentes como periodistas iraníes que
trabajan fuera de las fronteras
han sido objeto de amenazas de los
servicios de inteligencia en los últimos
meses por ejemplo en Gran Bretaña la
policía ha advertido de un aumento de
las amenazas por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad iraníes a un par de
periodistas británico iraníes y a sus
familias los principales blancos de las
críticas y de la persecución iraní son
periodistas que trabajan en medios de
comunicación que hablan en persa no como
la bbc persa o Irán International y
están acusados de incitar los disturbios
y Apoyar el terrorismo precisamente que
dice ese medio de comunicación Marta
Lira International el Irán International
dice ex alumnos denuncian el llamado de
profesores para reprimir a estudiantes Y
es que como sabemos los universitarios y
los jóvenes son unos de los promotores
de estas oleadas de protestas en el país
asiático y los graduados concretamente
de la Universidad de ciencia y
tecnología de Teherán critican a sus
profesores que hayan enviado una carta
que en la que pedían seguridad para
tratar con algunos alumnos disidentes no
sostienen que Este es el incidente más
vergonzoso de la universidad y desde el
inicio de las protestas ha habido muchos
reprimidos y detenidos en estos
complejos universitarios Pese a que la
ley iraní prohíbe a las fuerzas
militares entrar pero lo han hecho de
manera civil sea vestidos de civiles y
han perpetrado crímenes contra estos
alumnos para finalizar este tema
hace un artículo recogiendo unas
declaraciones de un futbolista sahan
godos un futbolista de la selección
iraní que jugará en Qatar a partir de
esta semana en la que decía que todos
queremos un cambio no son declaraciones
que hizo al Daily mirror al periódico
británico y dice que aunque no quiere
mezclar la política con el fútbol el
fútbol de alguna manera queda en un
segundo plano porque hay gente luchando
por la maltratar en su país pese a los
llamados a que de la FIFA que Irán no
compareciera en Qatar sí que va a estar
esta selección y el futbolista citado
por este medio sostiene que algo tiene
que cambiar porque la violencia no es el
camino bueno vamos a ver si algo cambia
Marta y no sigan perdiendose vidas en
ese país Lamentablemente pero
precisamente hablando de este mundial de
Qatar seguimos en ese país el golfo
Pérsico donde los aficionados del fútbol
que van a acudir a ver el mundial a ver
a sus equipos van a tener que hacer
frente a una larga lista de
restricciones no disfrutar uno dentro
deportivo para qué costo sin libertad
este periódico francés titula las
estrictas reglas que esperan a los
hinchas del fútbol en Qatar los fans del
mundial estarán sujetos a un régimen
prohibitivo sin precedentes aunque las
autoridades cataríes han informado que
se van a relajar estas restricciones no
recordemos que es un gobierno inspirado
en la aplicación no que es esta
aplicación más estricta del islam Raúl
se espera que haya al menos 1,2 millones
de turistas que comparezcan en Qatar en
las próximas semanas y por ejemplo
algunas de las restricciones desde el 1
de noviembre hasta el 23 de diciembre
solo están autorizados a entrar en el
país las personas que tengan una entrada
para algunos de los partidos de fútbol
el tema del alcohol solo se puede a
partir de tres horas antes de que
empiece los partidos hasta media hora
antes de que empiece y después una hora
después el afán Sound de doja la capital
solo se puede consumir alcohol a partir
de las 6:30 de la tarde y por otra parte
fuera de la fan son solo en hoteles y en
bares autorizados Aunque este país no
respeta ningún derecho lgtb y está
condenado con penas de prisión incluso
durante el Mundial han dicho las
autoridades que van a dar la bienvenida
a todos los aficionados sin
discriminación literalmente dice las
autoridades que no se aplicarán
restricciones a amigos de diferentes
sexo o parejas que se alojen en la misma
habitación de hotel además no se podrá
llevar ropa demasiado ligera se tendrán
que cubrir las rodillas y los hombros y
está prohibido por ejemplo fotografiar
instituciones gubernamentales llevar
medicamentos sin receta lleva revistas
pornográficas o importar carne de cerdo
Bueno al yesira hace también un análisis
es lo que dice los países anfitriones
ganan dinero con la Copa del Mundo
aunque se espera que 5.000 millones de
personas se conecten para ver el mundial
de fútbol y más de un millón comparezca
físicamente en Qatar no es del todo
rentable para los países que organizan
este evento deportivo no se hace mucha
inversión en infraestructura y la
mayoría de los beneficios se los termina
quedando la FIFA que por otra parte
también pues hace un gran
inversión en infraestructura sobre todo
de organización por lo que a priori no
sale rentable sin embargo dice este
artículo de al jazeera es una buena
herramienta de poder blando para decir
que esa infraestructura es buena para
invertir y hacer negocios en ese país
bueno Marta como siempre Gracias por
toda la información de esta revista de
prensa por el día de hoy mañana Claro
que sin más revista de prensa gracias